ooh okay have we played before
no oh we played once before it was a
peaceful result
how about among us next stream oh
uh i don't know i don't know how to play
among us
i'll play e4 here
there is some comment about agad matar
there should be a spanish form of agar
matar
saying eats eats eats eats so basically
komei kome kome
let's play an ortho schnapp
so i'm playing m singer's end game coach
so i just have to avoid an end game also
ortho shop time
hi eric oh hi little red lobster
thanks for sobbing for one year it's
already been one year
wow thanks so much
wait i don't even know i barely know
like what among us is i don't really
speak any fluent spanish so that would
be the ultimate challenge
but i can try
but i think i'll stick with chess for
the time being
eric primero can guarantee a million
views on
youtube with you and other pictures
youtubers
oh i know it's kind of a trend
but i don't know if i just followed all
the trends i'd probably be streaming
like fortnight right now
my opponent's playing well i'll play
this move
idea oh my bishop getting trapped
there's b5
and b5 might actually trap the bishop
i shouldn't have said that
wait a minute i can take
i think
and then the rook is kind of getting
trapped what's going on here
never among us
never among us oh oh the brad 777.
yeah i could just blacklist the phrase
among us from chat
whoa it's brad with a thousand bits
thanks brad but if i blacklisted among
us
people would just misspell it
to bypass the blacklist yeah look at
this move
so there's bishop b7 here because the
queen helps defend but bishop b7 i take
on
on b5
i think it's paying off diet
maybe i discovered a new did i discover
a new trap in the the ortho schnapp is
this made of just backfired
[Music]
to trabajo
i tried to say good luck with your work
yeah
adios hasta luego amigo
okay i can take this
uh yeah let's take this
rook still attacked this is yeah that
was expected
and now if queen b7
that rook is not getting untracked i
don't think
oh but there's queen b4 coming
wow queen b4
might actually save black
or does it
oh it's getting sharp oh actually queen
b4 i play bishop d2 my queen's still
defended and the rook's still trapped
this better still be okay it's a weird
position
but yeah the queen's attacked the rook's
attacked if takes takes
oh i think we're yeah that was a good
move
i guess we're just simplifying
wow we're gonna go into an end game that
was the one thing i was supposed to
avoid
if i have to play off three
not f3
i don't think i'm scared that bishop
takes f3
yeah let's develop so it's kind of equal
material
right it's kind of equal material
idea this move in this move
now black has a bishop here which is
kind of annoying
rook d1 is interesting wait the king
hasn't moved yet he's a kinka castle
i'll start with this i know my ambition
wants to go here probably some
play some combination of moves coming up
with the rooks
play this move this is actually a really
interesting endgame because i have the
majority
usually two minor pieces are stronger
than rook and pawn but the deeper we go
into the end game
the more the rook and pawn can be
valuable
i also have a small time advantage
especially an outside pawn can be a very
effective against knights
start with this
so i want to play this move then the
bishop
finds a very nice square
and of course there's always the option
of taking
also there's some ideas bishop bishop b4
the rook is short on squares
i guess there's that move
uh what to do takes takes
i'm trying to punish black for being
behind developments
taking like d4 so i have a little bit
more activity
measure d7 is a good move
in this move
now it's going to be an interesting end
game
a time scramble type thing
it's b3
e7 first
okay now we can take oh i don't want to
take though
i probably have to take i'm going for
knight c2
running this
yeah let's attack from behind i'm going
for this
here we go i really gotta watch the time
oh i'm winning the night
oh yeah i was getting really low on time
opponent was playing like quickly and
confidently
that was a good very good game um
this is a weird opening i'm wondering if
i've like
if i'm just not winning material after
bishop d7
that's some very resourceful play eric
are you doing anything for chess day on
saturday
oh saturday is like national chess day
right
or friday one of the days this week is
national chess day
um i'll be yeah so i'll be embedded on
the front page of twitch 2100 bullet on
liches thank you for all the tricky
gambit lessons
oh thank you undivided cloth oh
and median joe appreciate that
she should have taken on the dress
instead of
thank you for the game instead of basing
oh this move thank you for the game
maverick
yeah i feel like we entered one of the
the more critical lines
oh thank you abf chess
kaiser yeah it was a cool opening
like ortho shop theory is still very
kind of fresh
and um it's kind of like an unknown
dark forest there's many
different paths to be discovered oh but
we followed okay so
yeah starting from this position like we
played all the most popular moves
c6 is secondary but still very common
now i knew this idea of like sacking
this pawn it looks weird because i'm
allowing black to take and check me
but the point is i just complete
development in queensland castle
very easily went back the pawn
um so b5 was played
so this has been played uh 29 times
before
and we went into all of this i mean at
some point black does have this move i
don't know how useful it is though
i mean maybe this is a i don't know
oh it's close to equal wow
if we go back
yeah so this is kind of the line i was
remembering for bishop e3 and
computer will give like slightly better
for black but
like practically i think it's easier to
play for white
um oh d2 is interesting d2 king f1
that's so savage you just let the pawn
sit here on the second rank
after eight moves and you don't take it
because
this is the safest place for the king
and the rook still wants to
come to the d-file so a box probably
better with like very precise play
um but this is probably one of the
reasons why ortho schnapp is nice for
blitz
is because in order for black to get an
advantage
you have to go down a very kind of scary
line
so anyway thanks again to my opponent
thanks i'm singer this is uh this is a
fun matchup
end game i don't know what was going on
in that game
i mean all three results were possible
um it's actually a really interesting
imbalance
uh with two miners versus rook
so i might put that on youtube
definitely some lessons to take away
some uh i mean between the opening the
end game
you know people on youtube like these
exotic tricky dubious gambits
so if it does go on youtube youtube
people hope you enjoyed that
be sure to follow on twitch and
subscribe on youtube
that would be amazing it is
oh thanks i'm singer um
yeah and actually on youtube we're about
to hit
150 000 subscribers
so hopefully this week i'll run like a a
celebration arena
once we hit the number